[Musik]
herzlich willkommen ja mein heutiger
gast macht alles maximal sie ist eine
der bekanntesten vertreterinnen
deutschlands hat im alter von 25 jahren
einen ersten bestseller mit dem titel
alte weiße männer vorgelegt schreibt
eine kolumne für die zeit und hat einen
eigenen podcast mit komplett gänsehaut
hat sie ein neues buch geschrieben das
wiederum die bestenlisten stimmt und das
allerbeste
sie ist heute bei uns zu gast sie passen
ganz herzlich willkommen hallo danke ja
und worum es in ihrem neuen buch geht
das sagt uns auf die passmann gleich
selbst in der buch präsentation ihres
verlags hallo mein name ist so viel was
man ignorieren sie die menschen hinter
mir das sind leute die andere bücher
geschrieben haben aber heute geht es
ausschließlich um mich endlich geht es
mal um mich das internet fragen gestellt
zu meinem neuen buch das komplett
gänsehaut heißt und am vierten märz 20
21 erscheint 20 21 das jahr in dem das
volk nichts anderes möchte als hörbücher
in den zum generationen gibt es sind
viele fragen viele anfragen beantworten
um einfach mal ein gefühl für den
menschen zu bekommen der hinter der
maskerade steckt fand ich nicht anfangen
ok johannes fragt frau fasst man warum
dieses buch das ist eine passende weise
sehr sehr gute erste frage ich habe
dieses buch geschrieben weil ich in den
letzten jahren mich viel mit der
sogenannten identitätspolitik
auseinandergesetzt habe und festgestellt
habe oder immer schon dachte dass es
eine eine sehr wichtige theorie ist und
jeder sollte sich mit der eigenen
herkunft auseinander setzen
und siehe da ich bin ein westdeutsches
mittelschicht girl und westdeutschen
mittelschicht girls und boys thun ganz
oft so als sei ihre herkunft die die ein
bisschen allgemeingültiger ist als die
von vielen anderen ist sie aber gar
nicht und darum geht es in komplett
gänsehaut ein westdeutsches
mittelschicht score sagen sie sind sie
zufrieden mit ihrer identität
ja aber zufriedenheit finde ich gar
nicht so eine wichtige kategorie ich
glaube es geht erstmal ganz unemotional
und unabhängig von zufriedenheit
unzufriedenheit darum meint aus papier
zu gucken sagen ja das bin ich
und das kann ja je nach kategorie auch
ein bisschen schmerzhaft sein das
festzustellen also sie haben eben alte
weiße männer von vor zwei jahren
angesprochen
das hat ja auch nicht jedem mann mit dem
ich mich unterhalten habe spaß gemacht
aus papier zu schauen und festzustellen
aha ich bin überall tricks
ich bin weiße hautfarbe und ich bin ein
mann und ob die zuviel oder unzufrieden
waren war mir ein bisschen egal in dem
moment und deswegen finde ich jetzt bei
mir auch nicht wichtig ob ich zufrieden
oder unzufrieden bin damit sie haben ja
auch gesagt identitätspolitik ist ein
reizwort zurzeit sie sagen aber
eigentlich ist das auch eine chance
jeder sollte sich mit der eigenen
herkunft auseinander setzen
was gibt es denn dabei zu gelingen ich
glaube es macht ein bisschen die eigene
sprecht position klarer und das ist dann
so ein häufiges missverständnis sofort
wieder darüber gesprochen darf man
gewisse dinge jetzt nicht mehr sagen
oder nicht mehr denken darum geht es gar
nicht sein ganz im gegenteil dass man
das wissen um die eigene identität er
als erweiterung des sprech und denkt
raums begreift weil man auf einmal eine
zusätzliche perspektive oder eine
zusätzliche brille für die welt bekommt
weil zu verstehen dass ich auf die welt
blicke weil ich eine frau bin zum
beispiel weil ich ein westdeutscher bin
oder weil ich weiß bin oder zu einer
gewissen generation gehöre sorgt nicht
dafür dass ich auf einmal gewisse dinge
nicht mehr sagen darf sondern sorgt in
meinen augen eher dafür dass sich
gewisse dinge viel viel klarer sehe
und selbst wenn ich dann feststelle ich
als weiße frau zum beispiel möchte etwas
sagen was von gewissen leuten dann nicht
gehört werden möchte hat das immer noch
nichts mit sprech- und denkverboten zu
tun die dann im kontext von intimität
ganz oft sofort an die wand gemalt
werden
und ich frage mich immer wo es die
beweise dafür gibt darüber werden wir
später auch noch sprechen die ganze
diskussion um die kanzel couch wenn wir
noch mal darüber reden aber jetzt haben
sie ja schon eine ganz wichtige these
glaube ich in den raum gestellt nämlich
die eigene sprech position zu klären das
kann dazu dienen auch verständnis zu
schaffen für andere sprechen sie ziehen
zum beispiel sie sagen aber auch gerade
die westdeutschen mittelschicht kinder
sage ich jetzt mal die denken immer ihre
herkunft sei ein bisschen
allgemeingültiger aus diejenige von
anderen das heißt sie erklären
eigentlich das was sie erleben fast
schon zu norm genau also einem buch
versuche ich und vor allem die
erzählerin die sophie in dem buch
versucht das auf die spitze zu treiben
und mein versuch als autoren war es
eigentlich eine persiflage auf diese
allgemeingültigkeit zu schreiben weil
diese erzählerin mit einem habitus durch
die welt geht das mal
in meinen augen nach spätestens 50
seiten denkt muss mein gott was hat
diese frau eigentlich und meine
persönliche haltung dazu ist das ist
gerade durch die deutsche pop literatur
mindestens seit den 90ern sangen dazu
gibt gewisse generation erlebnisse und
erfahrungen zu einem allgemeingültigen
generationen erlebnis oder eine
erfahrung zu hoch zu schreiben wenn man
ganz viele tolle bücher die mich sehr
geprägt haben denkt florian illies
generation golf oder benjamin von
stuckrad-barre oder auch christian
kracht dass man dann das liest und denkt
na ja so sind sie halt die jungen leute
und es gibt aber cech identitäten die
nichts mit diesen männern zu tun hatten
oder haben die auch zur selben zeit
stattfanden was die bücher nicht weniger
großartig macht aber auch die
identitäten die nicht drin vorkommen
nicht weniger allgemeingültig und das
machen sie auch deutlich es geht ihnen
eigentlich sehr viel mehr um eine
milieustudie denn um eine generationen
studie
und ich würde gerne mal kurz mit ihnen
in dieses milieu eintauchen
also diese diese welt die einen da
sozusagen ausgebreitet wird da geht es
zum beispiel um eine foto mäßige
krankheit in der diese menschen wohnen
es geht so ganz viel ums wohnen und wie
man sich darstellt den wohnen
es geht aber auch um die pizza die man
neuerdings mit karamellisierten
walnüssen verspeist oder warum das die
menschen darin in irgendwelchen wg sie
in einem pro seminar zusammen
diskutieren und aggressiv auberginen
größten wie sie schreiben wirklich
glücklich und entspannt klingt das alles
nicht
nein diese milieustudie ist natürlich
auch eine literarische zuspitzung also
ich glaube ich habe das wenn ich das
buch jetzt mal unabhängig davon dass es
geschrieben habe in die hand nehmen und
reingucken gibt es viele momente wo ich
mich selber erkennen aber auch ganz
viele momente wo ich denke das ist eine
wahnsinnige zuspitzung von der wahrheit
und das ist auch das ziel von dem buch
dieses milieu durch zuspitzung zu
treffen
aber ich glaube die zuspitzung als der
trägerin kann man vor allem dinge
treffen
aber ja diese spaß bei freiheit die sie
ansprechen die ist glaube ich wirklich
in der wahrheit auch in diesem milieu
das es viel um darstellung vielen
darstellung durch konsum geht aber eben
auch gleichzeitig diesen konsum
moralisch irgendwie einzubetten in die
eigene welt
also dass man so zwischen zwei
lebenswelt ideen steht einmal den
hedonismus von den älteren generationen
und einmal dem aktivismus oder dem
moralismus von den noch jüngeren
generationen so und greta thunberg und
frau des the future wir stehen so
mittendrin ende 20 und gehören nicht zum
moralismus aber auch nicht mehr zum
hedonismus und ich glaube diesen versuch
beiden gerecht zu werden existiert eine
krasse verkrampftheit dass man ständig
versucht egal ob man gerade milch in
seinem café schüttet und mit der frage
konfrontiert ist kuhmilch oder hafer
milch genauso wenn man abends betrunken
nach hause kommt und eigener und döner
essen möchte ist man immer mit der frage
von so einer gewissen performance
beschäftigt es gibt dieses dauernde sich
beobachten eigentlich das einlaufende im
gang ist
ich habe auch sehr stark auch erinnert
an den roman von leif randt allegro pass
denn in dem die menschen sich auch
dauernd diese figuren sich beobachten
also da gibt es personen die sitzen im
yoga sitz auf einer matte und versuchen
zu meditieren und denken dauernd darüber
nach wie sie wohl aussehen wenn sie da
sitzen und meditieren und lernt schreibt
an einer stelle auch ein ganz wunderbar
es geht eigentlich darum leute zu
beschreiben die in berlin möglichst
publikumswirksam eine gute zeit haben
wollen ja ein bisschen beendet nicht das
ehrlich gesagt ja wenn ich auch es ist
interessant dass sie diese szene jetzt
von bertrandt ansprechen weil in meinem
buch gibt es eine szene wo es so um
lachen und wie demonstrativ lacht man
und wenn man bei dichter lesungen sitzt
wie nachdenklich guckt man in die welt
damit die leute merken dass man gedanken
versonnen ist aber nicht zu gedanken
versonnen das ist ein großes parallele
glaube ich dieses performative das leben
genießen aber nicht so sehr genießen das
man vergessen könnte dass man gerade
nach spielen muss dass man das leben
genießt also so ein anti heidecker quasi
niemals in die welt geworfen sein
das ist total demoralisierend aber die
welt ist natürlich auch nicht so wie
eine literarische zuspitzung der welt es
gibt auch orte wo man einfach ganz
normal sein kann und man kann auch in
berlin die orte wo leute performativ
hafer cappuccino trinken einfach meiden
man muss da nicht hingehen aber sie
interessant natürlich betonen sie jetzt
immer wieder das ist eine litauische
zuspitzung das ist natürlich auch bei
leif randt und in anderen büchern
und trotzdem denkt man da ist etwas
getroffen und ich finde es auch ganz
stark von ihnen dass sie sagen es geht
um ein milieu und gar nicht so sehr um
eine generation weil ich das selber in
meiner umgebung und ich bin eine andere
generation auch beobachte dieses eben
über alles so unglaublich fast schon
angestrengt nachzudenken und das
gegenstände plötzlich oder kleidung
alles wird zum signal in also man
versucht mit allem etwas zu
demonstrieren wie vogue man ist oder wie
sehr in man ist oder wie sehr man etwas
ablehnt wie sehr politisch wann ist uns
so weiter und noch einmal die frage der
termin ist das eigentlich ich glaube ich
muss ist die klischee junge person im
fernsehen spiel und sagen es hat mit dem
sogenannten internet zu tun ich glaube
dass soziale netzwerke sehr viel damit
zu tun haben dass wir gewisse
kommunikative probleme im echten leben
miteinander haben also meine generation
jetzt geht es wirklich um eine
generation weil es da um eine gesamte
generation elle erfahrung geht und meine
generation ist als erste wirklich
erwachsen geworden mit den sozialen
netzwerken es gab schon internet davor
aber ich bin als erste generation mit 11
12 13 schon in den genuss oder auch
nicht genuss von sozialen netzwerken in
meiner jugend geworden und ich habe also
gar keine jugend erlebt in der ich nicht
in einem digitalen raum durch ich
botschaften und affekte aufmerksamkeit
bekommen konnte das meine ich erstmal
wertfrei sozialen netzwerke
funktionieren nur über ich über self
hieß über meine meinung meine gefühle zu
denken
es geht eben nicht um dieser fakt
existiert es geht um was macht dieser
fakt mit mir und ich glaube dass das
einfach automatisch dazu führt dass man
in der gesamten auch dann analogen welt
diesen diese effekt behaftet hat ein
bisschen mit rein trägt zumal meine
generation auch und das ist hoffentlich
das letzte mal dass ich das meine
generation sage heute gar nicht mehr so
groß unterscheidung zwischen digital und
analog macht also für mich ist das
internet nicht ein anderer raum in den
ich gehe
für mich ist das internet eine ergänzung
vom analogen raum und das existiert
nicht mal parallel zueinander sondern
nur als eine entität und auch über
dieses internet wollen wir noch ganz
viel sprechen was ich wirklich ein sehr
interessant finde ist vielleicht so was
wie einen hula frage man kann ja sich
überlegen
ist es wirklich so dass das internet
und so verformt hat also die welt alles
was wir tun muss instagram möbel seien
heutzutage wir überlegen uns immer schon
wie sieht das aus innerlich den filter
auflegen wie könnte ich das inszenieren
für ein bild ins internet
oder ist es umgekehrt so dass wir
sozusagen schon so unterwegs waren und
deswegen so empfänglich für die sozialen
medien sind
ich glaube das ist eine frage die armen
aussee in seinem buch muster so klug
gestellt hat dass er gesagt hat naja
diese ganzen internet digitalen medien
social media wir sind so empfänglich
dafür weil wir vorher schon in einer art
und weise aus gesellschaft unterwegs
waren nämlich neoliberal verformt dass
wir uns immer aus ich-ag verbessern
wollen und uns darstellen wollen dass
ihr so empfänglich werden dafür also ich
finde das keinen schlechten tipp das
neoliberalismus beziehungsweise dann um
noch eine größere schiffe aufzumachen
spätkapitalismus damit zu tun hat wie
erfolgreich soziale netzwerke sind die
hunde frage kann ich nicht beantworten
meiner empfindung nach und das ist auch
meine empfindungen als relativ junger
mensch der die welt ohne soziale
netzwerke eben gar nicht mehr kennt ist
dass man am anfang
soziale netzwerke von sehr sehr schlauen
programmierern und erfindern hatte die
genau sich überlegt haben wie die
menschliche psyche funktioniert und dann
ja auch immer weiter dies das wissen um
die menschliche psyche
professionalisiert haben um uns dabei zu
halten um das sogenannte engagement hoch
zu halten also die art und weise wie
intensiv wir interagieren mit den
sozialen netzwerken und ich glaube ab
dem moment ab dem man diesen diese saat
hatte von einem system in dem alle na ja
ich sag mal schlechte eigenschaften
eines menschen unabhängig von der
gesellschaft in der er existiert wachsen
kann und gedeihen kann dann hatten wir
diesen perfekten sturm und dann kann man
einem punkt wo es naht von selbstläufer
wurde weil warum sollte ich denn nicht
als mensch an diesen ort gehen an dem
ich wahnsinnig simpel belohnung spüre
weil auch wenn wir das heute glaube ich
nicht mehr empfinden wenn ich mein handy
aufmache und durch instagram scroller
und irgendein like sehe von einer mir
völlig anonymen personen
dann empfiehlt macht das ja in meinem
gehirn chemisch was und das find ich
erstmal nachvollziehbar dass der mensch
nicht sagt nein diese kostenlose und
einfache belohnung der setze ich mich
nicht aus das heißt wahrscheinlich man
sagen sie selber sie ist eine ironische
zuspitzung ich möchte trotzdem wissen
was ist eigentlich das problem mit der
pizza die aufgepimpt wird die pizza
kommt immer wieder vor in dem buch uns
mal gesagt spritzig und das original
besser mit tomaten mozzarella und finden
diese karamellisierte walnüsse daraufhin
nicht gut es geht in dem buch weil es um
das milieu geht über das wir jetzt eben
schon gesprochen haben und weniger um
eine generation auch viel und klasse und
umfiel und klassenzugehörigkeit und um
geld das einem einen gewissen lifestyle
kaufen kann und eben auch nicht kaufen
kann und in der pizza bricht sich die
erzählerin aber da muss ich auch ehrlich
sagen auch für mich so eine art sehr
bürgerlich lifestyligen klassen hass
weil man dann sagt er pizza muss so sein
pitts also das allerneueste in hippen
stadtteilen von berlin das übrigens
sauerteig pizza die natürlich auch noch
mal drei euro mehr kostet das man da
zutaten drauf ballert die definitiv so
so ein distinktionsmerkmal sind dass man
einen gewissen preis erreichen muss für
diese pizza damit man auch eine gewisse
klasse oder ein gewisse schicht gar
nicht mehr damit erreichen kann
unabhängig davon dass die stadtteile in
großen städten ohnehin nicht mehr so
durchmischt sind in der regel dass man
jetzt eine pizzeria für ober- und
mittelschicht haben würde
aber indem ich auf eine pizza ein
ehemaliges arme leute essen wieder in
diesem buch erklärt wird mit
pinienkernen und und irgendwie gewickelt
rote beete und einem für die latte
beschmeißt sorge ich natürlich dafür
dass die 14 euro kosten muss man ja auch
für schweizer verhältnisse und witz ist
aber in deutschland das ist teuer und da
da geht es darum auch das ist zugespitzt
beschrieben aber da bin ich schon fest
davon überzeugt dass es bei den
kleinsten dingen in diesem
großstädtischen links liberalen
bürgerlichen milieu darum geht sich
abzugrenzen zu armen leuten ob man jetzt
im pizzaessen geht oder schuhe kauft
oder in die kneipe geht es geht immer
darum zu zeigen wer bin ich und vor
allem wer bin ich nicht oder dann
wiederum das original zu konsumieren das
aber so sehr original ist und zu berühmt
dafür das original herzustellen dass es
auch wieder teurer wird sozusagen
und das ist ja interessant dass sie ich
glaube das war im spiegel dass jemand
geschrieben hat sie sind eine art
andreas ragwitz in lustig das fand ich
sehr treffend andreas rettig während
reck wird das fand andreas ragwitz der
deutsche soziologe der mit diesem buch
die gesellschaft der singularität an ein
bestseller geschrieben hat und darauf
hinweist dass eine neue mittelschicht
eigentlich jetzt steht die ihr leben
nicht mehr einfach lebt sondern ihr
leben auf führt war es eben dauernd mit
distinktionsmerkmal und versucht sich
abzugrenzen nach links und rechts nach
unten und oben
das ist genau was sie zu zeigen
versuchen ja und er ich glaube ein
aspekt den ich ergänzt habe nicht weil
ich mir jetzt ein maß an der effekt wird
zu ergänzen sondern weil ich natürlich
kein sachbuch in dem sinne geschrieben
habe mit journalistischem anspruch
sondern literarischen text konnte ich
das dadurch ergänzen dass ich diesen
konsum noch viel mehr in den mittelpunkt
gestellt habe in dem ich diese
erzählerin eben auch nur über konsum
funktionieren lasse also alles was da
analysiert wird jeder gegenstand in der
wohnung jedes lebensmittel jedes getränk
jeder ort an dem man geht da geht es
immer um geld ausgeben oder geld eben
nicht ausgeben sachen haben oder sachen
nicht haben es gibt nahezu keine
menschliche beschreibung die nicht
abhängig von einem konsum sache ist und
das ist natürlich nur möglich weil man
sich den text bauen kann wie man möchte
und nicht an eine art von realität
gebunden ist aber dieses vorspiel und
dieses auch aufzeigen von leben
stadtleben zu passieren zu lassen
da sehe ich eine große parade es gibt ja
eine dinge die ist gleich geblieben und
da habe ich sie geliebt in diesem ein
spieler den wir vorher gesehen haben da
geht es nämlich noch um süßigkeiten und
wir haben etwas gemeinsam wir lieben
beide sitzungen und sie sagen die sauren
zungen die sehen zwar noch gleich aus
aber die sind nicht mehr so sein wie
früher
ich habe mir ein paar mitgebrachte kann
mir nachher testen und ich habe ihn
jetzt was ich bin ja eine generation
älter und die sauren zungen war
natürlich in meiner kindheit bestimmt
saurer als diejenigen ihrer kindheit das
ist ein süßigkeiten werden immer süßes
gerade sagt das über unser leben
da müsste andreas recht mit meinen
alltag artikel darüber schreiben genau
das sehen wir hier mit quasi zu
protokoll wir hätten gerne dazu eine
arbeit von andreas ragwitz aber die
machen nachher noch den test ich
erinnere mich aber wirklich noch daran
dass sie so dass man so das gesicht
verzogen hat ja ja aber das
war früher das ziel ging bis in die
ohren sage ich immer dass man da habe
ich nicht mehr erlebt ja aber ich möchte
trotzdem auch wenn sie jetzt ganz
ausgesagt haben zu recht gesagt haben
das ist eine milieustudie nicht ein
generationenporträt die wollen über
genannter zum ausgleich gehabt und kurz
sprechen ja weil es schon auch ein dinge
gibt die vielleicht spezifisch sind für
die sogenannten millennials also die
generation derjenigen die zwischen 1980
und den späten 19 90er jahren geboren
sind und etwas was ich so heraus gespürt
habe ist das thema angst es gibt einen
satz in diesem buch da sagen sie diese
leute da die haben immer angst mit den
falschen sachen spaß zu haben weshalb
sie sicherheitshalber gar keinen spaß
haben woher kommt diese angst ich glaube
weil es eine gewisse verwertungslogik
der eigenen freizeit gibt nur in diesem
jahr sage ich schon wieder milieu
ich kenne die generationen nicht gut
genug um eine gesamt aussage über die
generation treffen zu können
deswegen muss ich leider bei mir bleiben
weil ich es wahnsinnig unseriös findet
nicht als soziologin zu sagen meine
generation ist so weil mein milieus ganz
sicher so ich kenne niemanden der
einfachen lustiges robbie habe ich kenne
drei leute vielleicht die sagen das
mache ich einfach gerne weil es spaß
macht aber wenn man auf den gängigen
partys von so in solchen bürgerlichen
altbauwohnungen steht und dann fragte
was machst du eigentlich seiner freizeit
naja wandern gehen oder mit dem fahrrad
schön durch die karpaten oder ich lese
wahnsinnig viel keiner sagt ich spiele
gerne playstation 4
weil es immer auch ein bisschen darum
geht zu zeigen wer bin ich denn
und woher das kommt das weiß ich nicht
aber ich habe das gefühl dass die
freizeit auch sehr hoch gesetzt werden
muss zu einer semiotik die es vielleicht
gar nicht unbedingt verdient hat weil
eine freizeit einfach eine erholung ist
von der zeit die man nicht frei hat und
die ist ja manchmal schon schlimm genug
also eine stadt jetzt nicht aber eine
schwierigkeit ist natürlich auch
diejenige dass man etwas finden muss
wodurch man sich abgrenzen kann von den
eltern ich meine das ist völlig normal
dass man über die eltern hinaus wachsen
will und wenn ich an meine generation
denke da war ja klar man wollte das
spießertum der eigenen eltern irgendwie
überwinden und habe dagegen rebelliert
jetzt habe ich manchmal den eindruck
haben die jungen
menschen das problem dass die eltern
ebenso viel kiffen wie sie und in den
gleichen dating-plattform verkehren wie
sie also wogegen soll man eigentlich
rebellieren
mein empfinden nach riss das problem gar
nicht so sehr dass die eltern zu
laissez-faire sind oder weil weil also
ich zumindest bin zu jung für 68er
eltern deswegen habe ich diese erfahrung
gar nicht es kann vielleicht sein dass
wenn man so mit echten millennials
spricht die so in der regel mitte 30
sind das die noch echt 68er eltern haben
wo man sagt boah mama papa hört man
bitte auf mir dating tipps zu geben
meine empfindung nach ist das dass das
problem jetzt was meine generation hat
ein viel marktwirtschaftliche riss wie
soll man denn nicht verschließen in
dieser welt also wenn man keine
wohnungen findet in den städten in denen
man zum studieren in die die man zum
studieren gehen muss damit man in zehn
jahren vielleicht einen job findet der
dann die wohnung die man sich immer noch
nicht leisten kann fast halb bezahlt und
in diesen zehn jahren muss man 15
praktika machen am besten im ausland wo
man sich eigentlich nicht so richtig
leisten kann weil man noch studiert
damit man den job findet er die wohnung
nicht bezahlen kann usw
wie soll man denn da nicht schon mit 25
existenzängste bekommen selbst wenn die
eltern eine mine vielleicht weiches bett
aus erbmasse gebaut haben und bauen
konnten ich sehe hippie sein oder
freigeistig seien halte ich für riesen
lehrer kind privileg also leute die
wirklich wissen ich erbe ein bis zwei
häuschen meine mama kann mir auch noch
mal bezahlen wenn ich ein semester
länger arbeite der als studiere die
können sich leisten zu sagen hey leute
entspannt euch doch mal der kapitalismus
macht uns alle kaputt wenn man das nicht
hat woher soll man denn die muße nehmen
barfuß auf festivals zu tanzen
also das ist wirklich auch eine angst
die mit existenzängsten zu tun hat ich
glaube also vielleicht existenzängste
eine sehr große kategorie weil
existenzangst würde ich also die angst
kann damit sich eine valide sein aber es
ist ja faktisch so dass man ab einer
gewissen zugehörigkeit einer gewissen
schicht gar nicht so ohne abstiegsgefahr
hat wie man dann denkt aber wenn man
wirklich über die mitte redet dann ist
diese angst
nicht nur valide sondern auch
statistisch untermauert dass das richtig
sein kann dass man absteigt und gerade
wenn man in so einem alter wie anfang
mitte 20 wo das ja ganz wichtig ist sich
von seinen eltern abzukapseln sich
selbst selbst zu versorgen nicht mehr
irgendwie jeden monat die überweisung zu
sehen weil man jetzt nicht mehr studiert
einfach ein echter eigenständiger mensch
zu werden dass er für akademiker innen
klassischerweise das alter wo das dann
passiert dann ist es nämlich total
frustrierend wenn man auf eine welt
blickt und sagt ich kann einfach die
banalen sachen wie wohnung finden job
finden
bezahlbare wohnung finden einen job
finden der mich vielleicht einigermaßen
glücklich macht der auch vielleicht
unbefristet ist wenn diese simplen dinge
schon nicht funktionieren dann sehe ich
logischerweise anhang zur verbesserung
und nicht ein hang zur jetzt werde ich
noch frei geistiger sache und man sieht
darin natürlich auch einmal mehr die
ambivalenz der freiheit einerseits sich
selber entwickeln entwerfen sich selber
ein leben zusammenzimmern zu dürfen aber
ist eben auch zu müssen weil es diesen
großen lebensplan diesen sozusagen
vorgelegten teppich nicht mehr gibt wo
man einfach weiß das ist meine rolle da
geht das leben lang so sieht ungefähr
aus und auch darüber gibt so einen soll
ich sagen so was großes ganzes wovon ich
weiß ich bin da auch gehalten
also mögen das transzendentale ideen
seien oder mögen das auch einfach
soziale vorgegebene pläne seien wir sind
ja oder viele sind wahrscheinlich froh
dass überwunden zu haben um zugleich ist
ein holz der fehlt ja ich jeden menschen
in meinem alter der so eine art von es
ist ja auch wenn man popkulturell oder
wenn man eine art von subkultur heute
hat ist es eine art von nachspielen von
der alten subkultur also wenn ich heute
so leute in meinem alter see die so eine
68er hippie mentalität nachspielen
dann habe ich erst mal einen gesunden
respekt vor diesen menschen weil ich
entweder denke deine eltern sind so
absurd reich dass du dir das leisten
konnten oder aber du lebst in meinen
augen das missverständnis dass nur die
transzendentale idee reicht um zu
überleben heutzutage und das ist ebenso
nicht
nun sind sie sophie passt
ja sehr erfolgreich in dem was sie tun
ich habe es schon erwähnt sie haben zb
ein bestseller geladen bedeute weiße
männer mit 25 jahren sie haben diesen
eigenen podcast sie haben auch
unglaublich viele follower
hunderttausende von follower in den
einem sozialen medien um zu sprechen und
denken doppelt so schnell wie die
meisten anderen zumindest wie die
meisten schweizerinnen und schweizer der
schweiz ist auch keine kunst na ja das
gleiche doch bei den sauren zungen
weiter trotzdem sagen sie passiert es
ihnen immer wieder dass sie dann bei
dünnen dünnen kaffee in meetings sitzen
und man will ihnen projekte andrehen mit
dem titel sowie svend waren fühlen sie
sich manchmal missverstanden
ja aber ich glaube das hat jeder eine
künstlerin jeder ein künstler dass man
sich mal mit missverstanden fühlt weil
man sich ja so ne welt aus der eigenen
existenz gebaut hat also also eigentlich
man damit wirklich existenz im endeffekt
sinne dass man die als einziger durch
steigt und das ist eine sehr größten das
gefühl von einsamkeit also einsamkeit im
positiven sinne dass man ich bin die
einzige die weiß wie ich bin und das ist
super weil das auch bedeutet dass ich
die einzige person bin die mich mein
leben lang erträgt also ich weiß alles
über mich und ich bin trotzdem weiterhin
bei mir das ist eine ganz schöne
leistung und wenn man dann auch noch aus
dieser einsamkeit die gerade beschrieben
habe eine art von job baut weil ich mit
meinen gedanken und mit meiner mit
meinem selbst in die öffentlichkeit gehe
dann kann ich von niemandem verlangen
egal in welchem meeting egal wie nah
oder nicht nach mir eine person steht
dass die diese existenz in allem
begriffen hat und dann ist ein beispiel
wie ich krieg eine langweilige kolumne
vorgeschlagen ja er rührend aber es gibt
natürlich auch momente wo sei es in
buchrezensionen oder in anderen kritiken
fernsehkritikern man wird ja dann
ständig auch richtigerweise im feld und
kritisiert positiv oder negativ dass man
sich so fundamental missverstanden fühlt
gar nicht in dann im schaffen weil damit
kann ich gut leben sondern in meinem
sein dass ich denke wenn ich das in der
welt ausstrahlen habe ich mich dann
falsch verstanden oder habt ihr mich
falsch verstanden
und weil ich den reflex immer erst den
fehler bei an
dann zu suchen um sympathisch finde
denke ich dann automatisch habe ich
vielleicht diese einsamkeit die ich mir
über jahre aufgebaut habe auf eine sehr
schöne art und weise missverstanden was
genau kommt aus dieser einsamkeit raums
wenn sie gesagt haben sie bauen
eigentlich aus der einsamkeit heraus
ihre kunst ruhe ich meine einsamkeit
nicht in diesen sozial kitschigen sinne
wenn man an kinder oder ältere leute
denkt die aus dem fenster schauen und
hoffen dass sie endlich mal jemand
wieder besuche ich meine mit einsamkeit
diese einsicht dass man erst mal sich
selbst hat und das kann ja auch etwas
sehr tröstendes und schönes sein diese
einsicht weil man damit glaube ich auch
eine gewisse sanftheit sich selbst
gegenüber erarbeiten kann wenn man weiß
dass hat wir haben schon so viel scheiß
durchgemacht also ich und das tiefere
ich dass wir auch noch überstehen und
aus der einsamkeit kommt dann glaube ich
eher ruhe als eine traurigkeit es hat
überhaupt nichts mit traurigkeit oder
alleine sein
sie stellen ihr buch ja ein zitat voran
von john dietlingen und da heißt die
letzte zeile band more time also dieses
alleine seien eben ohne in diesem
anderen art in dieser negativen art und
weise einsam zu sein das ist für sie so
richtig eine kraftquelle auch das kann
auch passieren überall ein sein also ein
wirklich zeit ohne andere menschen aber
das gibt noch ganz viele andere wege ich
glaube einfach fest an therapie sowie
alle menschen das ist einfach eine super
möglichkeit sich besser kennenzulernen
aber wie gesagt einsamkeit bedeutet mich
unbedingt alleine sein und einsamkeit
ist auch nicht eben diese in meinen
augen leicht verkitschte idee von da ist
ein mensch ohne andere menschen und hat
niemanden und weiß nicht wohin mit sich
ich meine mit einsamkeit die einsicht
dass ich am ende des tages nur mich
selber habe das macht mich dann nicht
sein zu kämpfen das macht mich auch
nicht zu eigenbrötlerisch es sorgt er
dafür dass ich weiß ich habe immer eine
sehr sehr gute begleitung dabei nehme
ich mich selbst
das klingt nach einer guten idee sich
selbst immer dabei zu haben und sie
haben jetzt gerade das stichwort
gebracht einzelkämpferin sein
es gibt ja etwas was ich ja total
faszinierend finden hin dass sie nämlich
sehr früh
gerne handball gespielt haben das ist
jetzt nun wirklich nicht ein sport den
sich jedes mädel mal eben so aussucht
wieso handball
also ich glaube ich wollte ein teamsport
ich fand aber alle ballsportarten doof
wo man in unterschiedlichen feldern war
also war volleyball und tennis ich habe
als kind mal tennis gespielt aber konnte
ich nichts mit anfangen und der
tennisverein glaube ich auch nicht so
richtig
mein bruder wiederum hatte fußball
gespielt ein größerer bruder und dann
war eigentlich fußball auch raus weil
ich wollte er ist nicht im sport machen
denn andere aus der familie schon
gemacht haben und dann war da auch im
handball und dann sagen sie in einer
kolumne dass man bei handball etwas
lernen kann nämlich es ist jeder spieler
jede spielerin zu jeder sekunde wichtig
auf dem spielfeld weil man aus jeder
position tore schießen kann im handball
und sie hätten dabei gelernt handball
seien maximal brutale direktdemokratie
das müssen sie von einer schweizerin
erklären es gibt also ich will mich
jetzt in mit dem fussball vergleich
nicht so sehr aus dem fenster lehnen
weil es sein kann dass ich so wenig
ahnung vom fußball habe das ist alles
gar nicht braucht weniger ahnung
deswegen wird's nichts machen
jetzt wird dabei so ein klischee frauen
gespräch das wir wissen bald mit denen
ehen geschieden handball tonnen dass er
schon ich glaube im fußball gibt es ja
positionen diesen torgefährlich um
diesen nicht torgefährlichsten und es
gibt positionen die sind je nachdem wo
der ball auf dem feld ist er vielleicht
egal also wenn sich das alles vorm tor
abspielt ist jetzt nicht unbedingt dass
der torwart alarmiert sein muss auf der
anderen seite weil das sehr selten
passiert fragezeichen
das so dass dann so plötzlich einen
konter passiert der binnen drei sekunden
im tor landet dann ist bei handball
ständig so das heißt jeder kann und muss
sich durchsetzen und jede aktion von
einer wenn eine wenn eine person
entscheiden wie springers hoch und
versuchen tor zu machen dann kann das
ein tor werden das meine ich mit
direktdemokratie man braucht nicht
unbedingt die spielzüge mit vier anderen
feldspielern oder feldspielerinnen man
kann auch einfach wenn man groß ist und
gut springen kann und vor allem gut
werfen kann sagen ich versuche das ist
einfach mal um das kantor werden
das heißt jede und jeder hat eine chance
und trotzdem braucht das ganze team in
diesem spiel
und dieses visum fdp
aber dies ist diese einsicht wir sind
ein team und gemeinsam sind wir stark
jetzt sind wir ganz stark bei den
slogans war denke ich so wie ist es
eigentlich so viel poznan zu sein von
der wahrscheinlich viele denken die
braucht gerade kein team liess alleine
so stark die marschiert durch und kann
es ohne uns was für eine art von meinen
sie privat oder beruflich lässt sich das
so trennen
ich versuche mir das sehr stark zeit
also ich versuche das nicht dahingehend
stark zu trennen ich bin auch befreundet
mit einigen menschen mit nichts zusammen
arbeite aber ich brauche das ganz
dringend dass ich an irgendeinem punkt
entscheide ich bin jetzt nur privat da
deswegen gibt es auch bereiche wo ich
selbst wenn leute mich sehr sehr
freundlich ansprechen in einem
restaurant oder auf der straße oder so
wenn ich da gerade sehr privat bin dann
kann es auch mal sein dass ich kein foto
mache oder dass ich irgendwie jetzt
nicht mich unterhalten möchte weil
dieses schützen von so sehr privaten
räumen wenn man in der öffentlichkeit
steht in meinen augen ihre wichtig ist
gleichzeitig versuche ich aber auch zu
akzeptieren dass die die öffentlichkeit
eben auch logischerweise bedeutet dass
es weniger private räume gibt als bei
einer privaten person ist es immer ein
teamsport jede art von öffentlichkeit
also ich bin großer fan davon dass man
alles was im fernsehen passiert oder
gerade alles was mit ein bisschen so
einer art von medienöffentlichkeit auf
personenbezogen zu tun hat zum ein
bisschen zu entkriminalisieren
es ist irre viel arbeit ist einfach
allein eine person ist damit beschäftigt
mich anzuziehen eine andere personen
schlink nicht so das muss nicht sein
aber irgendeinen punkt ist das so
dann gibt es die dritte person die meine
termine machen muss wenn ich dann
irgendwo rum stehe und es gibt noch eine
person die beim fernsehen sich dann
darum kümmert das was anderes passiert
also es geht ist es nie eine person die
sich hier ständig schreibt das buch beim
verlag ist es
ich habe eine fantastische lektoren
monat lang ohne die wären meine bücher
nicht so wie sie sind ich habe einen
tollen verlag dem ich vertrauen kann
ich habe eine fantastische frau die
diese cover macht ich habe einen
großartigen fotografen gehabt der das
buch de foto gemacht hat es ist immer es
braucht ein halbes dutzend personen
damit man überhaupt eine vernünftige
sache der öffentlichkeit machen kann und
sie machen ganz viele dinge ziemlich
vernünftig oder so
vernünftig sogar zumindest sehr
erfolgreich eines ihrer ganz großen
themen ist der feminismus und das ist
eben habe ich schon erwähnt dieses buch
alte weiße männer hat das sehr deutlich
gemacht haben sie interviews geführt mit
berühmten männern über sexismus und
versucht mit ihnen ins gespräch zu
kommen
es gibt im moment auch einen film den
man im internet immer noch ansehen kann
von joko und klaas er heißt in
männerwelten ist für den grimme award
nominiert und in diesem film führen sie
durch eine fiktive ausstellung eben die
männer welten ausstellung da werden
unter anderem so genannte dix enthüllt
also bilder von penissen die frauen
ungefragt zugeschickt werden und frauen
lesen auch haus kommentare aus dem
internet vor
wie gehen sie persönlich eigentlich mit
solchen haus kommentaren um mich
persönlich treffen die nicht mehr so aus
zwei gründen zum einen weil ich jetzt
schon genug gelesen habe weil als frauen
der öffentlichkeit ist es irre was man
sich so anzahl an zu hören hat und das
auch völlig unabhängig davon was man
macht also ein großer lernprozess beim
drehen von männerwelten war als andere
moderatorinnen kollegin von mir ihre
haas kommentare vorgelesen haben und wir
alle völlig unterschiedliche sachen
machen sachen sagen sachen aussehen und
alle kriegen dieselbe hast kommentar ist
völlig irrelevant was man macht man
kriegt die das heißt findet so eine art
von abhärtung statt zum anderen weil
sich aber auch einfach wo ich nicht mehr
rein gucken wo ich nicht mehr ein lese
weil warum sollte ich mit dem gemeine
sachen über mich durch lesen wollen ich
gehe ja auch nicht ich leide ja auch
nicht der schulhof aber zu einem
kindergeburtstag ein also ich kann das
auch einfach von mir fernhalten und der
wichtigste punkt aber ich habe
mittlerweile einfach gute anwälte die
ich mir leisten kann das wissen statt
das dass das ist das eigentliche hat ist
auch wirklich schon verfahren ja
natürlich ständig nicht ist es dem und
also demoralisieren viel geld gebe ich
dafür aus dass irgendwelche vollidioten
die bei der staatsanwaltschaft darüber
schreiben was ich finde dumme [ __ ]
bin und das irgendwie weg zu halten und
es ist auch teilweise sehr
demoralisierend was da so durchgeht bei
der staatsanwaltschaft was bejaht wird
aber dass es auch wenn man dann so
akteneinsicht bekommt und dann liest was
da für anzeigen vor
moniert wurden wo ich dachte das findet
er juristisch relevant dass der mich
nicht mag und das ist das perfide an
diesen hass kommentatoren dass die ganz
genau zu wissen scheinen bei wem sie es
noch abziehen können bei wem schon nicht
mehr weil die suchen sich eben nicht
also klar jeder krieg erst mal hast aber
es gibt so eine art von justiziablen
hast die kriegt man irgendwann nicht
mehr und zwar ab dem punkt wo die wissen
ja okay die kann sich anwälte leisten
und bis dahin das passiert dann bei
grünen politikerinnen ganz prominent im
deutschsprachigen raum dass politik
passiert bei feministinnen die jetzt
nicht besonders rasen gut bezahlte
kolumne den linken zeitungen schreiben
das passiert bei ganz viel über
transaktionen passiert dass man weiß die
machen wichtige arbeit die haben
vielleicht ein buch in dem kleinen
verlag geschrieben
aber man ahnt da ist jetzt irgendwie
nicht die ressource dar
um sich juristisch wirklich zu
verteidigen und bei denen machen die das
bis zum erbrechen bei mir nicht mehr
das heißt sie haben schon eine art von
umgang gefunden ganz viele frauen
natürlich nicht und was das internet
eigentlich genau mit dem feminismus
machten ich habe keine art mit umfang
damit gefunden ja ich habe einfach das
privileg genug geld zu haben um kein
umgang damit finden zu müssen
danke für den für die korrektur das
stimmt das ist eine große eine große
unterscheidung das ist das ist absolut
richtig
aber was überhaupt feminismus und
internet miteinander zu tun haben oder
inwiefern das internet im feminismus und
den feministischen kampf auch noch
einmal verändert war gibt es eine frau
die moment auch sehr klug darüber
nachdenkt und das ist die
us-amerikanerin diakonin tino die mit
trick mehr im moment auch die
bestenlisten stürmt sie gilt vielen so
ein bisschen aus die susan sontag der
millennials um die höheren ja mal ganz
kurz zu
es gibt dieses gewaltige aufblühende
stimmen von frauen und people of colour
in den medien stimmen und perspektiven
die so lange aus dem mainstream
ausgeschlossen waren sind endlich hörbar
doch was trügerisch ist und in die
falsche richtung in den sozialen medien
führt ist zb bei instagram diese
fokussierung auf das individuum
den persönlichen erfolg und das ringen
um likes da gibt es eine version des
feminismus die damit verschmitzt als
wäre es für minister gesehen zu werden
und beifall zu bekommen
der wirtschaftliche motor des internets
ist die kommerzialisierung des ist
sozusagen das selbstbewusstsein
profitabel zu machen
ein mechanismus der frauen schon immer
ein geprägt war die influenza industrie
auf instagram das sind zu 90 prozent
frauen
ihnen wurde immer gesagt verbessere ich
präsentiere dich so dass du gemacht wird
sei schön solche dinge ein paradigma
dass mehr frauen als männer betrifft
weil es einfach ein uraltes muster ist
tolentino beschreibt hier die
neoliberale kommerzialisierung über die
wir vorher schon gesprochen haben des
internets und sie sagt das betrifft die
frauen sehr viel stärker aus die männer
stimmen dazu ja social media
funktioniert über wie sehe ich aus wie
wirke ich wie bin ich also ich kann es
noch mal das sagen was ich gerade gesagt
hat in ein bisschen plump noch deutsch
und ich das ist natürlich etwas was
kulturell vor allem mädchen beigebracht
wurde dass das wichtig ist
und mehr als das sogar es ist ja schon
ein rollen bruch wenn männer auf einmal
eitel sind und dann kommt immer die
große erzählung von ja aber david
beckham und es gibt ja mittlerweile auch
metrosexualität aber das klischee vom
mann ist weiterhin ein nicht zu einer
mensch zu sein und ist dann er fast
schon unmännlich wenn man sich zu sehr
in szene setzt zu sehr pflegt zu sehr zu
eitles helfe es macht und deswegen finde
ich es völlig einleuchten dass es vor
allem frauen sind ob ich gut finde ist
die andere frage
und die frage ist ja auch könnte man das
nicht anders machen sie haben mal in
einem interview gesagt sie würden dass
man ein bisschen ärgerlich finden oder
auch was so ein bisschen neidisch auf
die männer gucken dass die im fernsehen
auftreten können wie die haut aussehen
während wir uns da irgendwie aufhübschen
was weiß ich noch alles
könnten wir ja vielleicht auch ändern
ich glaube ich habe über deutsches
fernsehen gesprochen weil in amerika
muss man sagen es ist
auch was anderes also in amerika
herrscht ja eine ganz andere
professionalisierung von entertainment
im deutschen fernsehen geht mir manchmal
das messer im sack auf um es mal ganz
gut gestartet zu sein wenn ich sehe dass
leute nicht mal irgendwie sich das hemd
gewechselt haben bevor sich eine
talkshow gesetzt haben geschweige denn
das herdfeuer gebügelt das hat dann für
mich nichts mit männlichkeit und
weiblichkeit zu tun sondern eher mit dem
privileg nicht auf äußerlichkeiten
reduziert zu werden und deswegen auch
nicht gezwungen zu sein die extra arbeit
zu machen die frauen machen müssen weil
ich kann mir jetzt schon wenn ich also
nicht jetzt sondern wenn ich in der talk
show ordentlich angezogen bin kann ich
mir jetzt schon was anhören
eine äußerlichkeit stell dir vor ich
komme darum gebügelten bluse und
irgendwie einem knopf ab und eine hose
mit einem riss drinnen dahin dann ist es
bei mir nicht gültig sondern irgendwie
ein bisschen eigenartig und ungepflegt
und ich werde als frau gezwungen wenn
ich nicht ein gewisses bild unfreiwillig
vermitteln möchte mich darum zu kümmern
bei einer gewissen gruppen männer im
fernsehen geht das dass sie das einfach
ignorieren andererseits bin ich aber
auch großer fan von sich ein bisschen
mühe geben im fernsehen äußerlich also
auch mit klamotten
deswegen finde ich das ganz gut dass
mich meine weiblichkeit oder meine frau
seien in der gesellschaft dazu gezwungen
hat auf mich acht zu geben
um trotzdem ist es so dass dieses system
sage ich jetzt mal uns frauen ganz
anders eben dazu zwingt darüber
nachzudenken wie wir aussehen das haben
sie jetzt gerade auch noch einmal
bestätigt sie sagen in ihrem buch etwas
extrem kluges sie sagen nämlich was uns
eigentlich genau noch einmal die
bahnbrechende erkenntnis dass das system
das problem ist wirklich bringen soll
und über diese frage habe ich eine weile
nachgedacht und habe gedacht ich frage
noch einmal vielleicht hätten wir es
zusammen raus er hatte auch für über
nachgehen und ich habe ja auch ein
bisschen in den blöden trick gemacht
dass ich einfach aufgeschrieben habe
ohne die fragen dann am ende zu lösen
ich habe es nur festgestellt und
beobachtet was ich in
bei jungen leuten im internet
feststellen so bei jungen linken
aktivistischen leuten im internet dass
diese feststellung reicht das system ist
schuld
also die ich würde sagen die perfideste
ausformung davon ist natürlich glaube
ich weiter bei primark ein weil se der
kapitalismus der die welt kaputt gemacht
hat und wenn ich nicht bei primark
einkaufe dann ändere ich die welt nicht
also dieses ohnmächtig sein ob der
bestehende umstände führt zu einem sich
selbst aus der pflicht nehmen moralisch
als es eine völlige auflösung von einer
moralischen kategorie oder einem
moralischen selbstanspruch im eigenen
handeln was eine interessante
philosophische auflösung von einer ganz
wichtigen menschlichen kategorie ist
weil die frage ob mein handeln die welt
verändert ist eine völlig andere als was
für ein mensch ich sein möchte und wie
handeln möchte und ich habe das gefühl
diese auflösung dieser moralischen frage
im eigenen handelns ist so passiert also
meant das müssen wir kurz festhalten sie
sagen wir denken heute fast nur noch
darüber nach wie kann ich die welt
verändern dann denke ich kann ich eh
nicht also spielt keine rolle
und wir denken zu wenig darüber nach aus
den menschen sein wollen
endlich will daraus gar nicht so eine
grosse wir sache machen
das beobachte ich vor allem bei linken
kapitalismuskritischen jungen menschen
die gibt es im internet zuhauf das ist
eine immer wachsende subkultur mit
eigenen kurz und eigene sprache und und
eigenem politischen forderungen und die
sind dann eben auch so links dass sie
zum beispiel diesen falsche falsches
land hier aber diesen europäischen union
school von so linksliberalen falsch
finden weil doppelpunkt aber da ist die
einsicht na ja wenn ich jetzt keine fast
fashion kaufe ist der kapitalismus immer
noch der der alles kaputt macht und ich
bin doch auch eine frau das heißt ich
leide unter meinem körper weil wir haben
eine patriarchale gesellschaft außerdem
habe ich wenig geld weil kapitalismus
natürlich kauf ich billige kleidung
außerdem wir sind weiter mit catalis
muss auch wenn ich keinen auch wenn ich
nachhaltige klamotten kaufen und diese
hoheit von maine mein handeln muss das
system verändern so hat dafür gesorgt in
meinen augen dass man dann sagt er dann
kaufe ich weiter bei primark dann kauf
ich weiter bei h&m dann kauf ich weiter
bei zara weil es ändert ja eh nichts und
diese begründung da schwingt ja mit wenn
man habe keine persönlichen moralischen
ansprüche an mich ich habe nur noch
gesamtgesellschaftliche systemische
moralische ansprüche an mein handeln und
das ist eine ganz interessante
paradigmen verschiebung jetzt ist dies
interessant weil es mich als philosophin
extrem interessiert und weil ich
wirklich tatsächlich denke es ging zum
beispiel bei immanuel kant früher mal
wirklich darum was bin ich für mensch
kann ich eigentlich vor mir selber
geradestehen also der respekt gegenüber
dem gegenüber ihnen ist auch ein respekt
gegenüber mir und gegenüber dem
moralischen gesetz und nicht einfach nur
welt verbessern und wenn ich das nicht
kann im alleingang dann lass es bleiben
genau und es wäre ja auch völlig in
ordnung oder es ist sowieso alles völlig
in ordnung ich will gar nichts
anprangern
aber man könnte ja auch durchaus diese
debatte zu ende führen dann feststellen
ja es gibt ein
es gibt zum beispiel kein moralisches
handeln wenn dadurch sich nicht
moralisch die welt verändern lässt weil
wenn die welt so verrottet ist dass man
durch moralisches handeln die welt nicht
besser machen kann sind wir in einem per
se unmoralischen system und dann ist
quasi frucht des verdorbenen baums
könnte man ja sagen
diese debatte wird ja gar nicht geführt
es wird ja gar nicht darüber gesprochen
also in meinen augen wird gar nicht
darüber gesprochen warum und wie es
diesen paradigmenwechsel gibt weg vom
moralischen selbstanspruch von handeln
hin zum mein handeln muss die welt
verändern was wir übrigens
entschuldigung bei der bei dieser
generation unfall des futures wieder
anders ist und dass man ja sagen die
verbinden ja eigene moralische selbst
ansprüche mit dem versuch system zu
verändern
und wissen sie was ich interessant
findet aussprechen wie immer von der
generation greta und ich glaube weil
auch wiederum es ist ein milieu absolut
also das finde ich auch wichtig
festzuhalten dass betrifft da nicht alle
aber ein guter punkt das stimmt das
verändert sich bei denen jetzt haben sie
mehrere male von der moral gesprochen
und vom moralischen selbstanspruch und
was im moment ja auch so wahnsinnig
auffällt und das geht wahrscheinlich
allen so ist dass die moral im moment
ganz schlechte karten hat man mir waren
brüllt dauernd hilfe moral terrorrat
hensel die technologiebranche
das lehnen sie ab also sie sind der
meinung es gibt im moment keinen moral
terror sondern wir sollten durchaus
darüber nachdenken wie moralisch durchs
leben ging natürlich ich weiß überhaupt
nicht warum man auf einmal frauen haben
sich jahrzehntelang an
gehört dass sie hysterisch sind wenn sie
immer und immer wieder die gleiche sache
vehement fordern was haben sich für mich
was haben sich denn meine mütter und
großmütter generationen an hysterie
vorwürfe anhören müssen weil sie
vehement auf etwas parat haben
plötzlich hören wir seit 34 jahren
liberalen männern dabei zu wie sie immer
und immer wieder dieselbe falsche sache
grünen nämlich moral terror cancel
culture und wir hören mit einer bier
ernsthaftigkeit zu die mich wirklich
fast schon schockiert also nur wenn man
eine also die wird nicht wahrer nur weil
man es immer wieder in viel zu lange
schlecht geschriebenen essays
aufschreibt es gibt keine moral terror
nur weil wir eine bessere welt wollen
es gibt auch keine moral terror nur weil
eine junge klimaaktivisten skandinavien
sagt es wäre toll wenn wir uns noch eine
welt übrig lässt in der wir leben können
was denn daran im ural terror was das
überhaupt für eine für eine
menschenverachtende wortschöpfung eine
ein punkt den wahrscheinlich viele da
aus diesem lager sage ich jetzt mal
machen würden ist dass man sagt naja wir
verbieten 100 dinge wie er sind sowie
eine terroristische gruppe unterwegs und
gucken uns dauernd an was die anderen
machen und bewährten alles also dieser
bewährten der blick auf das verhalten
der anderen der dann auch dazu führt
dass gewisse dinge nicht mehr frei
gesagt oder frei gedacht werden können
und gerade sie als künstlerin aus satire
karin sind ja auch darauf angewiesen
dass es zum beispiel so etwas gibt die
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit absolut die
verteidige ich auch immer kunst und und
meinungs- und pressefreiheit ich finde
dass die aufgabe gerade von gegenseitig
satiriker innen zu einander sehr viele
dieser tiere von einer person doof fand
oder platt oder bescheuert dass man das
verteidigt dass es nicht angegriffen
wird im kern des sagbaren das ändert
aber nichts daran dass ich immer noch
auf die beispiele warte für denk und
sprech- und überhaupt verbote es wird
dann immer so eine vage uni heran
gezogen wo irgend ein dekan in amerika
gesagt hatte darf jetzt nicht auftreten
wo ich immer noch sage ist es ein
sprecher oder denkverbote da ist es
nicht einfach nur ausüben von hausrecht
also wenn ich zu einer veranstaltung
gehe und der besitz der der klub
betreiberseite sie dürfen keine
regenschirme mit reinnehmen und ich darf
dann nicht mit rein weil ich einen
regenschirm dabei hatte ist es auch kein
mit
für verbot von regenschirmen ist einfach
nur jemand der sagt ich möchte dass in
meinem haus nicht deswegen darf ich ja
immer noch woanders hingehen und
regenschirme dabei haben genauso dürfen
intellektuelle immer noch an anderen
orten reden publizieren denken sagen
also wo gibt s denn die beispiele für
die für die denk und sprechverbote und
ich ärgere mich so über diese über diese
wörter die moral terror oder auch immer
die cancelled
weil ich finde es geht so obszön
leichtfertig mit solchen kategorien wie
freiheit und nun denkt räumen um weil
wenn ich das jetzt einfach brüllen kann
dass die freiheit eingeschränkt wird und
man mir wird gehört weil es irgendwie
wird zugehört weil es irgendwie
aufregend klingt dann begreife ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht wie solche leute
sich dann noch intellektuelle schimpfen
können
ich verstehe auch auf sie raus wollen
vielleicht mit ich mag's und der anderen
seite gerne verlieren gibt es denn für
sie dinge von denen sie denken das ist
wirklich satire die geht zu weit oder
würden sie erst mal sagen nein es darf
eben wirklich alles gedacht und gesagt
werden es darf alles gedacht und gesagt
werden
und jetzt können wir glaube ich an dem
punkt wo es wohl meinen augen ein großes
missverständnis gibt was ist kennt halt
schauen was es keine cancel culture weil
wenn leute sagen das ist kein zufall
jetzt darf man diesen witz ja gar nicht
mehr machen was die eigentlich meinen
ich durfte diesen wird es früher machen
ohne gegenwind
heute kriegt gegenwind der gegenwind es
aber keine kämpfe kalte der ist debatte
wenn wir also sehr aktuelles beispiel in
deutschland ein satiriker vom
bayerischen rundfunk hat black fans
gemacht dass wurde ausgestrahlt wurde
geschrieben
das wurde abgenommen das wurde gedreht
das wurde geschnitten das wurde in der
finalen version an moderiert ab
moderiert abgenommen und gesendet und
jetzt gibt es gegenwind deswegen weil
leute sagen das ist ein rassistische
praxis dann sagen andere leute nein
sagen andere leute doch dann
entschuldigt er sich und es passiert
nichts
das ist dann ein modernes beispiel für
cancel culture weil leute gesagt haben
wir finden diese art von satire
rassistisch das ist doch es passiert
doch nichts
es gibt nur mittlerweile eine größere
gruppe von leuten die sich ihrer
identitäten und ihrer spezifischen
identitäts erlebnisse bewusst sind und
mitreden dürfen natürlich
war satire und kabarett und comedy
vor 40 jahren in deutschland einfacher
weil da gab's halt 25 männer aus
westdeutschland weiß und zwei frauen die
sich als putzfrauen verkleidet haben und
das war dann kabarett und wenn heute es
verschiedenste identitäten und und und
erfahrungen gibt dann sagen einige naja
ob du deine sowie zu machen solltest da
ist es für mich ehrlich gesagt einfach
nur eine debatte darüber wie man bessere
comedy machen kann und nicht eine art
von cancellara der mann hat immer noch
seinen job da wird auch seinen job
behalten
also kann man eigentlich daraus
schließen solange
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit wirklich gilt
und hochgehalten wird redefreiheit
wirklich hoch gehalten wird aber kritik
möglich ist und zwar von allen
richtungen und es um eine debattenkultur
geht so lange haben wir keine cancel
couch im engeren sinne
da würde ich mit ihnen mit gehen dann
gibt es natürlich aber auch die form von
kenzo culture wo man wirklich sagt diese
texte wollen wir nicht mehr lesen
diese starten dürfen hier nicht mehr
stehen also wir holen jetzt den kampf
vom sockel holen den hegel vom sockel
und wir wollen die straßen umbenennen
und so weiter ja das ist für mich jetzt
noch mal wirklich was anderes weil ich
da jetzt nur spezifisch über kunst
gesprochen habe und kultur weil ich da
wirklich vehement der meinung bin wenn
leute das als kämpfen kalt empfinden
müssen sie sich schlicht und ergreifend
ein bisschen mehr zusammenreißen weil
wir haben jetzt das internet und da
dürfen andere leute mitreden was diese
historische nachträglich interpretation
von philosophen zum beispiel angeht bin
ich auch der meinung das ist völliger
quatsch ist zu sagen na ja aber der war
ja antisemiten kann ich nicht mehr lesen
ja wer war denn nicht antisemit wer ist
denn heute in manchen ländern nicht
antisemit werden manche parteien heute
nicht antisemit also deswegen
philosophen zu canceln
statt sich intellektuell mit der
damaligen zeit auseinanderzusetzen
das halte ich für seine person kurz
gedacht internet zuspitzung von sehr
komplexen problemen
das andere sind die historischen zweite
also dass ich wo sie gerade von den
büsten sprechen
das gab es ja ganz prominent in den
staaten das auf einmal kolonial
denkmäler geköpft und runter gezogen
wurden
da wurde ja so getan als würde man
geschichte vertuschen wenn man aber mal
ein bisschen den blick weitet oder ein
bisschen den zoom rauszieht ist ja dass
köpfen dieser statuen erstens auch eine
völlig normal eine historische praxis
und jetzt teil der geschichte die gerade
geschrieben wird man kann ja trotzdem
darüber debattieren könnte man diese
stadt und stehen lassen wenn man eine
andere neben stellt könnte man sie
ersetzen kann man diese person überhaupt
noch verehren warum verehrt man sie
überhaupt aber diese debatte dann schon
zu canceln kalter zu machen wo sie
eigentlich nur ein intellektueller akt
ist das finde ich auch so eine
verniedlichung von den personen wieder
gerade protestieren und die statuen
abhauen weil das sind ja nicht diese das
sind ja nicht irgendwie menschen zweiter
klasse die jetzt auch ein bisschen
mitdenken wollen
die haben nur eine sehr nachvollziehbare
andere sicht auf diese statuen
sie ist eigentlich etwas was ihr kern
aus der historisch kritischen arbeiten
der wissenschaft dass man dinge
kontextualisiert aufarbeitet indem man
den kontext eben sichtbar macht und
genauso kann man ja auch mit solchen
werken mit statuen usw umgehen dass ich
etwas was benedikt zum beispiel immer
wieder eine sehr eindrücklich fordert ja
auch schon bei uns zu gast war
ich sage übrigens entschuldigung weil
ich jetzt glaube ich so ein bisschen arg
entspannt euch wirke ich sage deswegen
überhaupt nicht dass alles was da gerade
passiert ist ich bin zum beispiel bis
heute noch nicht abschließend sicher ob
man nachträglich literatur das n wort
raus streichen sollte man braucht ganz
sicher mit arabischen umgang damit
man braucht doch ganz sicher mit
naturwissenschaftlichen umgang damit
aber ich sage jetzt nicht bei jeder
neuerung aus dem internet oder aus einem
gewissen milieu ja herr damit wir machen
alles anders ich wünsche mir eigentlich
vom konservativ-liberalen milieu dass
sie diese entspannung und souveränität
die sie immer rum behauptet haben in den
letzten jahrzehnten jetzt mal unter
beweis stellen weil die müssen nichts
anderes tun als einfach mal kurz die
füße still halten und sich entspannen
und beobachten was da gerade passiert
und dann einen klugen gedanken finden
dazu und nicht sofort brüllen die neben
uns unser leben weg weil das ist kein
zufall
ich würde gerne zum schluss noch einmal
mit ihnen zurück kommen auf die frage
was das internet eigentlich mit unserem
leben an stellt ihre figur sagt in
diesem
komplett gänsehaut an einer stelle ich
glaube nicht dass das internet je gut
für mich war ist das internet gut für
sie frau passen wenn man jetzt mal
psychisch als langzeit kategorien nimmt
mit sicherheit nicht karrieretechnisch
ganz sicher aber ich kann mir nämlich
kein leben mehr ohne internet vorstellen
also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie an die
dinge im internet denke die mir passiert
sind so cyber mobbing in der schulzeit
was ungefähr jedem schulkind basiert
oder heute schlimme hass kommentare
irgendwie morddrohungen böse kommentare
zu mir meiner person so dass endlich
alles nicht schön
nur ist die frage wäre es ohne internet
nicht auch irgendwie passiert aber ja
ich wäre mit sicherheit ein
ich wäre ein dünnerer und glücklicherer
mensch ohne dass das ist vielleicht
schön zusammengefasst aber mal ganz
abgesehen von diesem haus kommentaren
gibt's ja auch das phänomen das wir
feststellen dass das internet sozusagen
fast in unserer denkweise denke mein
dringt das beschreibt im moment ganz
klug mienack und seine schweizer
schriftstellerin in dem kleinen buch ich
denke ich denke zu viel da gibt es einen
text mit dem titel ich hasse dieses
internet 1 1 titel eines buches aus den
usa einig ursprünglich und sie
beschreibt darin wie sie das gefühl hat
wenn sie denkt dauernd sozusagen tabs
offen zu haben
also dieses internet ist wie in uns
eingeflossen und man kann sich fast
nicht mehr konzentrieren mal einfach ein
buch lesen ohne dauer berieselt zu sein
und ohne dauernd hin und her zu springen
zwischen diesen tapste im kopf offen
sind ja das stimmt
ich habe aber genauso festgestellt dass
man sich das auch wieder abtrainieren
kann indem man zum beispiel
benachrichtigung auf dem handy
ausstellen dass mein erster zaubertrick
und dann noch das handy einfach wirklich
es gibt ja auch apps die sagen du darfst
1 stunde nicht ans handy
klar ist das suchtverhalten aber wir
wollen ja die sucht loswerden dann
einfach hinsetzen und das handy nicht in
die hand nehmen das ist ja bei allen
sachen so man muss hier einfach machen
damit man sie macht und das ist glaube
ich bei handy los werden und diese
denkweise die sehr hügelig ist weil sehr
internetaffin auch loswerden ja ist nun
glaube ich eine achtsamkeit aufgabe von
gizeh so tierisch aber ich glaube das
ist die
richtige kategorie aber ja das internet
hat ganz definitiv haben sie das nicht
auch manchmal dass sie mittlerweile bei
was analogem zoomen wollen und dann sinn
machen das machen wollen und meine
kinder lustigerweise aber die frage ist
ja schon wie gehen wir eigentlich damit
um dass wir feststellen wir haben etwas
geschaffen was uns viele vorteile bringt
aber jeden die gans bei ganz vielen
menschen mittlerweile auch ein unbehagen
losgetreten hat die das lieber wieder
loswerden möchten ja so ein bisschen ein
zauberlehrling problem ja und ich denke
immer so sehr konkret überlege mir was
könnte man dann sehr konkret machen
ich glaube man bräuchte es zum einmal
sind das smartphone knicke aber so eine
ist eine etikette weil so eine art von
unruhe ja auch zum beispiel existiert
weil man gespräche führt aber dann
parallel sieht jemand schreibt mir vom
handy und dass man darüber spricht dass
diese priorisierung ja genau so ist wie
das jemand vorbeikommt und der ist
gerade spannender deswegen sage ich
warten sie ganz kurz diese person es
gerade spannender deswegen die ich da
hin dass es wahnsinnig unhöflich und
hibbelig ist zum beispiel ist ein
stehempfang krankheit dass man immer so
immer so an an den kopf dass die person
mit der man gerade spricht vorbeikommt
um zu gucken ob da jemand spannendes ist
sonst unglaublich umgänge damit finden
dass man wirklich dass sich bewusst
machen was die sozialen netzwerke mit
einem wollen nämlich mehr zeit
verbringen damit man mehr daten denen
gibt und zuletzt ich glaube das ist
jetzt sehr langweilig politisch man muss
natürlich diese riesigen
monopolunternehmen ganz klar vielleicht
verstaatlichen wenn aber wenn nicht
verstaatlichen sehr klar regulieren
ich hoffe sehr der verlag von ihnen kux
geradezu und hat sich notiert neues buch
mit sophie passmann social media knicke
internet knigge ich glaube dass wir
einschlagen wie eine bombe ich werde
dann gerne wieder mit ihnen darüber
sprechen frau passen
die ist doch wünsche ich mir und ich bin
sehr für dieses gespräch frau passen
danke ihnen sehr angenehm vielen dank
ja nächste woche diskutiere ich mit
wolfram eilenberger und gästen am
philosophischen stammtisch väterchen
staat tatsächlich nur mein bestes will
wenn er eine zuckersteuer erlässt oder
nicht zu impfen ermuntert und falls ja
ob ich ihm mein bestes geben muss und
jetzt gleich geht's auf zur
kehrichtverbrennungsanlage von
kopenhagen
sie ist nicht nur ein architektonisches
meisterwerk sie brilliert auch durch
nachhaltigkeit unten wird müll verbrannt
oben fährt man sie mehr über das
visionäre projekt jetzt gleich im film
making mountain visionär sein und
bleiben vielleicht kein schlechter
vorsatz in diesen engen zeiten halten
sie gut durch bis bald
[Musik]